[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احداث السادس من يناير 2021 قصه الالاف من
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين هددوا
الديمقراطيه التي يدعون انهم يدعمون
[موسيقى]
روابتها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في السادس من يناير كانت تلك فرصتهم
الاخيره لقلب النتيجه حين اجتمع الكونجرس
لتصديق على فوزي في الانتخابات
اغنيه الصين ما حصل هنا في اي بلد اخر ان
يقتحم الناس مبنى الكابيتول في يوم
التصديق على الانتخابات لا سمينا ذلك
انقلابا والاطلقنا عليه اسم جمهوريه الموز
والعلق مجلس الشيوخ جلسه التصديق وقام
ضباط الحرس الرئاسي باجلاء نائب الرئيس
اكون لم استطيع الالتفات كان الامر اشبه
بمشاهده حطام حطام قطار يسير ببطء انت
تشاهد شيئا يصعب تصديق لم يتم اعداده
بطريقه اخرى
[تصفيق]
لقد ركعه واحده من اكبر الديمقراطيات في
الكوكب وعلى الرغم من ان الشرطه تتمكنت من
تفريق متظاهرين في نهايه المطاف الا ان
امريكا والعالم اصيب بالظهور كيف امكن
لاقوى دوله ان تكون ضعيفه لها هذا الحد
ان شاء الله تهدوا المعلقين على تلفاز
يقولون حسنا هذا غير مسبوق هذا شيء لم
يحدث من قبل في الواقع لقد حدث هذا من قبل
عده مرات في التاريخ الامريكي لم تكن هذه
المره الوحيده التي حاول فيها مثير شاب
قلب الانتخابات
اسفل حصار السادس من يناير عن مقتل خمسه
اشخاص والقي القبض على اكثر من 600 شخص
على علاقه بما حدث الغضب ما يزال قائما
وتخشي السلطات هذا التهديد الداخليه
الجديد وكان الامه تخاف من نفسها من العنف
المحلي
[تصفيق]
دينا
قال هذا ليس ما نحن عليه كان في حاله
انكار لما كنا عليه
الكنيسه كل يوم احد مع كتابهم المقدس
يرتلون الاناشيد ايضا
تم بناء مبنى الكابيتول الامريكيه
الكونغرس بتصغير العبيد
من يناير يجب ان نعود الى مسرح الجريمه
الاصلي
منذ عام
1776 كانت فكره ان تحمل الميليشيا السلاح
للدفاع عن الامه جزءا من التفكير الامريكي
في الواقع هذا هو السبب في ان التعديل
الثاني يحمي حق الشعب في الاحتفاظ بالسلاح
وحمله ولهذا شعر متمرد السادس من يناير
بانفهم له ما يبرروه وسواء اعترفت
الولايات المتحده بذلك ام لا فانها تقع
على تقاطع خطوط النار حيث يسود العنف من
الحجيج الاولي الى الكفاح من اجل الحقوق
المدنيه هذه امه قامت على الحب ولاول مره
في تاريخها هذا العنف قدس اقداس
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
يعني كلمات
الابيض
الشغب التي ذلك
لا يعرف الكثير نراسل بانكس لكن كتبه هي
افضل طريقه لفهم امريكا في ازماتها هذه
الروايات العظيمه عن تجربه الطبقه العامله
تقدم لنا نظره ثاقبه عن روح امريكا
ومظالمها وانقساماتها العميقه ربما يكون
السبب الرئيسي للتوتر هو الانقسام المذهله
الذي كان موجودا دائما واشنطن وبقيه
الولايات المتحده
هو القلب الديمقراطيه الامريكيه فان
المركز الجغرافيه للولايات المتحده يقع
بالقرب من الحدود الشرقيه لولايه ويوم
ويؤمن هي الولايه الاقل اقتظاظا بالسكان
وهي التي منحت دونالد ترامب افضل نتيجه
لله يطلق على مدينه كاسبر اسم مدينه النفط
حيث شكل النفط المصدر الرئيسي للدخل لفتره
طويله جدا في ولايه ويومين الغرب الامريكي
الى الابد لا يزال البطل المستقل والوحيد
قدوه باتريكس وليفان هو واحد من هؤلاء
الرجال العصاميين الذين يشعرون بالقلق من
اي شيء يحاول شخص ما فرضه عليه
تدير اهلي حسابات الشركه وتحتفظ بوظيفتين
في المدينه هي وزوجها بات اللذان يحبان
الصيد والطبيعه لم يحضر قط اي تجمع سياسي
لكنهما يفتقدان الرئيس السابق الذي تم
اسكاته حسب رايتهم
وصلت اليه البلاد كم عدد الاشخاص الذين
يشترون صحيفه اليوم من وجهه نظر ارى انه
تم تزويرها تماما كانوا يكرهون هذا الرجل
لدرجه الاقدام على فعل اي شيء لقد اخترعوا
فيروسا للتخلص منه انظر الى التصويت عبر
البريد انظر الى تزوير الناخبين انظر الى
ما حدث خلال الانتخابات كان الموت ان
يصوطون هذا مثبت لا يمكنك ان تخبرني انه
لم يتم تزويرها لا يمكنك ان تخبرني ان
احدا المال
الى امريكا الجنوبيه واوروبا وافريقيا
مع ذلك لم يشعر يوما بالغربه في بلادهم
الى هذا الحد
عندما وقعت احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
البلد كله مهما كان لونك او انتماؤك
الحزبي شعرنا جميعا انه شيء فظيع يقشعر
بدني عندما اتحدث عن ذلك
باكملها وقالوا يجب ان نصلح هذا الامر ثم
سنجد اولئك الذين فعلوا ذلك لم يكن هناك
اقسام كما لدينا اليوم لا يشبهوا ما نمر
به اليوم عندما علموا ان هناك تجمع عن
حشدا مع ترامب وتجمعات ترامب بشكل عام
تجلب الكثير من الناس اينما
ساعات انا لست من انصار نظريه المؤامره
ولا مكان لها في حياتي فلدي ما يكفي من
الاعمال ولكن هذا امر غريب اعتقد انه تم
دفع المال للذين ذهبوا الى الكبريتول كنا
نعرف اشخاص كانوا في تجمع ترامب بينما كان
هو يتحدث كانوا لا يزالون يقتحمون مبنى
الكابيتول اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من
الدوافع الخفيه من كلا الجانبين الان في
الولايات المتحده يجب ان تكون مناهضه
للعنصريه لا يكفي ان لا تكون عنصريه بل
يجب ان تكون مناهضا للعنصريه ماذا يعني
هذا لا اعرف ماذا يعني ذلك مع اني ذكيه
جدا بصراحه لا اعرف انها فقط اعيش حياتي
الصغيره في يومين مع بطاته ودجاجتي وامل
الا يبدا العالم في الاحتراق من حولي اقصد
انه لا حيله
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هناك جرح كبير في مجتمعنا لا يمكن
التضميده ببساطه انه كبير جدا
دوله منقسمه ضد نفسها
في هذه المرحله
لا اعرف من يمكنه او كيف يمكن التعافي من
هذا الانسان
كان مثير الشغبي في السادس من يناير فريقا
غير متجانس منهم من جاء مستعد من الاقنعه
والسترات الواقيه من الرصاص والعنصريون
البيض يروحون بشاره التفوق الابيض و كيو
انو من اصحاب نظريات المؤامره لكن
الغالبيه العظمى من الناس التبيع الحشد
ببساطه غير مدركين انهم تعدو الخط الاحمر
كان من بينهم شاب يدعى كالب جونز وبعد 12
اسبوعا تعرف عليه مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي كاحد مثلي الشغب في الكابيتول
ولاول مره في حياته استشار كلب محاميا
يجب ان نتوقف عن التلاعب ببعضنا بعضا انت
تلف وتدور لقد صادفت هذا المشهد حيث يتقدم
الناس وبعض رجال الشرطه يحاولون منعهم ثم
اختلط الحابل بالنابل وبدا المكان وكانه
يتعرض للاختراق نحن نتحدث عن حصار مبنى
الكابتل اليس كذلك
نعم
انا هنا لمساعدته لكن لا يمكنني مساعدتك
وانا لا اعرف ما الذي حدث انا المحامي انت
الرجل الذي كان هناك كيف دخلت المبلغ
تسلقت الجدار نعم قررت ان اسرع طريقه
للوصول الى هناك كانت القيام بذلك ولكن
لو فكرت لمده 15 ثانيه
[موسيقى]
وقد حكم عليه في نهايه المطاف بالخضوع
للمراقبه لمده 24 شهر ربما لم يخترع الدول
سياسيه لكن الرئيس الخامسه والاربعين
استفاده من الغضب الذي شعر به العديد
الامريكيين وهم نححهم قوه وشرعيه من مقتل
جورج فلويد الى مبنى الكابيتال كانت ساندي
باشون تغطي الاحداث من خط المواجهه هذه
الصحفيه مستقله توثق انقسام بلدها وتنصد
الازمات التي تعصف به
يقول الناس ليته كان ناجحا لكننا بل لقد
كان ناجحا وما زال مستمرا اراه في حافلات
نيويورك عندما يتشاجر الناس ثم هناك ما
يسمونه كارنز وهن من النساء البيض لقد كنت
اصور تلك النساء المناهضات للمطاعيم والتي
تحولنا الان الى حركه دعم الشرطه لقد جعل
ترامب الجميع يفقدون عقولهم لاربع سنوات
اخذت رامبو يتلاعب منها
الروحي المدمن على الكحول ونحن كاننا 200
مليون من اطفاله
ذئاب اغسطس 2017
قديم للجنرال روبرتلي قائد جيش الولايات
الكونفدراليه
[موسيقى]
وفجاه
ظهر امامي هذا الرجل الذي يرتدي قميصه
هتلر وتسالت في نفسي من اين يحصل المرء
على قميص هتلر
كان متظاهرون يصرخون اللعنه على النازيين
وكان النازيون يردون اللعنه على انتفا
[موسيقى]
خ
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
موجود
لا احد منهم له تمثال ما يعرض من التاريخ
لذا غالبا ما يقول الناس التاريخ يكتبه
المنتصر
حسنا وهو ليس حنينا الى الحرب الاهليه بل
حنين الى حلم الناتج حقا على الخيال
امريكا الرعويه التي كانت بيضاء ومسيحيه
لم تكن موجوده ابدا
[تصفيق]
كان ذلك مذهلا
كان
العنصريه في الشارع رقم اربعه عندما
اقتحمته سياره يقودها شخص يؤمن بالتفوق
العرق الابيض ويبلغ من العمر 20 عاما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فاشون
اعتقد ان ما حدث هنا مع مقتل هبه رجل على
الكثير من الناس يدركون انهم ما كانوا
يهتمون من قبل ومن فيهم انا لم اكن انتبه
نشانا في الجنوب كنا نعرف ان كيكه
والنازين الجدد وحليق الرؤوس واشياء من
هذا القبيل موجوده
في فتره طويله لذلك لم اكن القي لهم بالان
اعتقدت انهم اغبياء ومازل
لكنهم الان اغبياء منظمون
شارلوتشيل مدينه صغيره وهادئه حيث اجتمع
تشباح وامريكا تمت ازاله التمثال في نهايه
المطاف لكن الرموز الماضيه تطارد البلاد
منذ تاسيسها
الانجليزي
نفسك والحقيقي
التشكيك في تاريخ بلدك يتطلب منك اعاده
النظر في تصورك لنا وبالنسبه لبعض
الامريكيين الذين يعتقدون انهمتهم هي اعظم
امه على وجه الارض فان هذا عمل مؤلم
[موسيقى]
ما حدث قد حدث لم اكن على قيد الحياه
حينها ولا اعتقد ان هناك شخصا ممن عاش
العبوديه لا يزال على قيد الحياه حدث ذلك
منذ زمن طويل لكنه يبقى جزء من التاريخ
عند التخرج من المدرسه الثانويه عاده ما
يكون لدى ابناء ويومين خيار اما مواصله
دراستهم او الذهاب لكسب المال في حقول
النفط
[موسيقى]
والان لديك اداره لا تريد البحث عن النفط
والغاز انهم يواصلون تصيب الحصول على
تصاريح والتمكين من استخراج النفط من
الارض وهذا يصيب الناس بالتوتر لاننا لا
نعرف ما الذي سيحدث لا نعرف مدى جنون هذه
الاداره الاسريه
لكن الحياه لا تسير على هذا النحو
وايه لم يعطيني احد شيئا كل ما لدي كسبته
من كدي وكان الامر صعبه
لن استطيع قول ذلك بشكل افضل انت على حق
هذا لمعنى له بالنسبه لي
واعتقد ان رؤيه الحلم الامريكي تتغير الى
المزيد من التسول بدلا من العمل
82 عاما وفقد ساقه وسيبحث عن عمل لو تركته
يفعل ذلك
الورشه لي والبيت لزوجتي
[موسيقى]
ترامب لقد خاسر
الثاني من الدستور الحق في حمل السلاح
مباشره بعد حريته التعبير
المسلح بطريقه خاطئه الفنادق لا تقتل
الناس الناس يقتلون الناس
يقتلون بعضهم اعتقد انه اختلال عقلي اكثر
من كونه سلاح نحن لا نقتل الناس لا اريد
ان اقتل اي شخص اريد ان اطلق النار
الا في حال التحدي اذا بدا احد بالعبث
باشياء فقد يتغير موقفي
ايا كانت النتيجه فان المعادله النهائيه
في الولايات المتحده هو الحق في حمل سلاح
ناري او هكذا كتب الروائي وليام تيفول مان
لكن الحقيقه هي ان الامريكيين من اصل
افريقي حرموا طويلا من هذا الحق
1967 دخل 30 فردا من الفهود السهود
المسلحين بالكامل مبنى الكابتل في ولايه
كاليفورنيا
على قانون جديد يمنعهم من القيام بدوريات
المسلحه في الشوارع ولم تطلق رصاصه واحده
في ذلك اليوم لكن الصوره كانت قويه بما
يكفي للجمهوريين بقياده رونالدو
سلاح الناري في كاليفورنيا
هذه هي المره الوحيده التي يخرج فيها ان
ارى اللوبي والقوي جدا والمؤيد للسلاح
لصالح تقييد التعديل الثاني ومع ذلك فانه
لا يقول شيئا عندما يكون هناك اطلاق نار
في مدرسه ارتكبه شاب ابيض
في لوس انجلوس اليوم هناك متجر واحد
للاسلحه يملك الامريكيون الافارقه ويقع
بجوار عياده طب الاسنان ومحل مساج اسيوي
تتذكري
واحد لذلك انت مستعده لاي شيء يمكن ان
تكون يدك هنا ويمكن ان تكون على الكفه في
اي مكان ترتاحين له وهنا لا داعي للسهم
ليس على رقمك وهكذا كلما اطلقت النار
حسنا هل نحن سعداء
ههه
هذا اول سلاح ليكي
الاحذيه لن ترتديها مع كل زين لدي لماذا
تكتفين بسلاح الناري واحد انها تقوم
بوظائف مختلفه
يتطلب القانون الفيدرالي للتحقق من خلفيه
اي شخص يشتري سلاح ناريا في 2020 مليون
فحصا في اسبوع واحد
[موسيقى]
اصحاب اصحاب
كانت تجربه سيئه كم امراه سوداء ذهبت الى
متجر من الاسلحه الناريه ولم يرغب احد في
الاجابه على اسئلته حتى انني سالتهم ان
يوصوا بالتدريب او المدرب وقالوا انهم لا
يعرفون اي شيء وانا اعلم الان بعد امتلاك
متجر للاسلحه ان ذلك ليس صحيحا
هناك حوالي 50000 متجرا للاسلحه في
الولايات المتحده يذكره موظفون مبيعات كل
مشترين جديد اذا لم تتدرب فقد تصاب
بالاذان
تسعه متاجر
الاسود
ومن كل الاطياف اذا نسيت احدا ارجو
المسامحتي لدينا نادي السلاح الايراني
لدينا كل انواع المجموعات العراقيه
المختلفه التي انشات نوادي الاسلحه الخاصه
بها لان الاسلحه الناريه انقذت ارواحا
اكثر مما ازهقت
في عام 2018 كان هناك ما يقارب
393 مليون سلاح ناري متداول في الولايات
المتحده لكن الارقام اصبحت بلا معنى
ظهرت اعلام جديده
او اداره الاطفاء او القوات المسلحه او
حراس الامن
يبدو ان الامريكيين اصبحوا يتمترسون حول
اعلام مختلفه اعتمادا على اولوياتهم او
المجتمع الذي ينتمون اليه
يعني
نقاشا دقيقا وعاطفيا حول قضيه العرق اكثر
من اي وقت مضى في التاريخ الامريكي لم
يحدث هذا من قبل في التاريخ الامريكي لقد
توقفنا عن الكذب حول هذا الموضوع ونحن
نفهم كيف هل هذا الفهم سيؤدي الى اتخاذ
اجراء لالغاء الفصل العنصري
[موسيقى]
لم يتجمع الحشد هنا في تونس صباح هذا
الاحد لحضور قداس الكنيسه الاعتيادي ولكن
للاحتفال بالذكرى المئويه للمجزره التي
راح ضحيتها 300 شخص ربما لم تسمع بها ابدا
لانه تم استبعادها من كتب التاريخ لحقوقود
واعضاء يساعد على تضميد جراح الماضي التي
تم التستر عليها لانها لا تتناسب مع الحلم
الامريكي
سكس
[موسيقى]
يوتيوب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
غزه عدد من المتمردين البيض المنطقه تم
تسريحهم من قبل مسؤولين مدينه وقتلوا
عشوائيا ونهبوا الشركات
تم اسقاط القنابل الحارقه من الطائرات
وكان ذاك اول قصف جوي على الاراضي
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
لم تسلم الكنيسه من ذلك تم تدمير 35 مبنا
في 18 ساعه فقط وترك 10,000 من السكان
السود بلا ماءاه
وقام الحارس الوطني بجمعهم في اكواخ وقيمه
على عجل على الجانب الشمالي من المدينه
جاء في عناوين اليوم التالي اثنان من
البيض قتل
ويعتقد العديد من الخبراء الان ان ما لا
يقل عن 300 شخص قد قتلوا لقد كانت مذبحها
اندلعت بسبب شائعه مفادها ان مراهقا اسود
اعتدى على امراه بيضاء في مصعد
خارج نطاق القانون والعنف طوال القرن
العشرين واواخر القرن 19
تفوق العرق الابيض الهوى سوف السود الذين
يرتكبون العنفسيه ضد النساء
هم الذين يغتصبون النساء السوداء
ايا كان فعله حين ذلك انا لست طبيبا نفسيا
ولكن هذا له علاقه بعوده الواقع المكبوتي
من العبوديه
الرجل الذي التقط هذه الصور سليل العديد
لقد صارت جزءا من الذاكره ذاكرتها هؤلاء
الاشخاص الفخورين والانيقين الذين اصبحوا
فخرا مجتمعهم بعد ان عاشوا لسنوات عديده
في ظل العنف المستمر
الامل في ان الحلم الامريكي لم يكن محصورا
في البيض بل هو وعد لجميع المواطنين
الامريكيين لم تتعافى منطقه ابدا اعيد
بناء الكنيسه وحدها ولتاكد من ان الجميع
قد نسي وعدت الحياه لطبيعتها قامت سلطات
المدينه ببناء طريق سريع عبر منطقه هذا
الطريق السريع يؤدي اليوم الى الاحياء ذات
الاغلبيه السوداء في شمال على بعد عشره
كلمترات
[موسيقى]
جدا وكمان
السود والبيض
ان بدا الامريكيون من اصل افريقي يعيشون
في مناطق معينه
المرافق الصناعيه والمرافق الملوثه اما
تلك التي قضامها
اقصى ومعدلات اعلى من امراض القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه
لا يوجد سوى مركز تجاري واحد في جميع
انحاء شمال وهو متهالك كبقيه الحي هنا
فالذكر المئويه للمجزره يحس الكثيرون
بالقشعريره يتحدث الاطفال عن ذلك في
المدرسه لكن الاحتفال يهم المنشغلين
بكفاحهم من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه عن
التفكير في الماضي
كثيرا لذلك بحثت عنه لنفسي
لم يكن ابدا شيئا تم الحديث عنه الا داخل
دائرهك الخاصه جدتي كونها ناجيه من عنصريه
في البدايه تحدث عن كيف كانت السوداء ذات
يوم وكيف راتنا نتجول وكانت الكلمه التي
ستستخدمها هي ان يكون كانت جميع يرتدون
ملابسهم ويحتمون باعمالهم وكان ذلك قبل
حدوث الكارثه لذلك في قرار نفسي بعد حدوث
ذلك اعتقد ان احد اعظم الاشياء التي فقدت
منذ ذلك الحين هو الامل فعندما تكون طفلا
وترى شخصا ما يزدهر في اعماله فانت تفكر
يمكننا القيام بذلك ايضا
[موسيقى]
بنوته
الى الافق الى جزيره مانهاتن باكملها لا
يوجد مبنى الرئيسي واحد يملكه شخص اسود
ولا واحد ولا واحد
الابراج
رئيسا واحدا في هذه البلده من منهات
لا يزال دونالد ترامب يتجول ويقول انه فاز
في الانتخابات التي خسرها
واسمحوا لي ان اخبركم كيف
المفارقه انهم يقولون الجناح اليمني
والجمهوريون يقولون انهم حزب قانون ونظام
حياه الشرطه مهمه لكنهم ذهبوا الى واشنطن
في السادس من كانون الثاني يناير وتمردوا
توفي خمسه اشخاص ماذا حدث لحياه الشرطه
مهمه في السادس من يناير انت لا تعتقد ان
حياه الشرطه مهمه انت تؤمن بالتفوق الابيض
وسوف تضع قواعدك بحسب ما يناسبها
[تصفيق]
في السادسه من يناير 2021 لم يكاد
المقتحمون يحطمون النافذه الاولى في مبنى
الكابيتول حتى بدات وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تعجب بالشائعات التي لا اساس
لها من الصحه وكانت تقول ان مثلي الشغب من
شطاي حركتي حياه السود مهمه وانتفا
متنكرون في زي انصار ترامب اصدرت لجنه
الكون رساله التي تحقق في التمرد مذكرات
استدعاء متعدده
[موسيقى]
التعبير عن الغضب في نظامي
فان اول سؤال
افترضنا منه
قلوب طيبه
في يونيو 2021 كان جوبايدن اول رئيس
امريكي يعترف بان الاحداث التي جرت في
تونسيا هي مذبحه
للمره الاولى في تاريخها تواجه امريكا
ماضيه المظلم
لكن هذا النقد الذاتي يخيف الناس ويخشى
البعض ان يفقد بلدهم وموقعهم خلال هذه
العمليه سوف يستغرق الامر بعض الوقت لعلاج
الانقسام ولان الغضب والخوف يسيران جنبا
الى جنب فان على كل امريكيه ان يبدا
بالاجابه على هذا السؤال البسيط ما هو شكل
العنف الذي تخشاه اليوم
اكثر من غيره
الا تشعر بالامان عندما تكون في الخارج
وان تشعر بالقلق اذا كان سينظر اليك على
انك تشكل تحديدا
[موسيقى]
او نوويه او حرب اخرى في الشرق الاوسط هذا
هو العنف الذي اعتقد انه وشيكو
كان بعيد
هو الارجح احتمالا لا شيء اقرب منه الي او
الى اي شخص اهتم به حقا لماذا
الناس لان لدينا سكان مطربين لان لدينا
بيئه كتنجره الضغط انها مجرد مساله حسابيه
انها مساله وقت
اكثر
او يحاسبهم احد ابدا
اكيد لا استطيع ان اقول ان الخوف ليس جزءا
من القضيه لكنني لست خائفا
القائمه على التنمر لكن بقدر ما اخشاه
اكرهه اكثر
حرب
الكيميائيه ولكن كما تعلمون انا اعيش هنا
في يومين انا حقا لست خائفا
ذا فويس
شكله العنف الذي رايناه في السادس من
يناير في الكابيتول
حياتهم ومستقبلهم واماتهم
[موسيقى]